[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  hi it's frank the tasty producer behind  this video i have some tips for making  the fruitcake so the first step is to  not skip on rehydrating the fruit it is  going to give your dry fruits this  beautiful soft and plump texture that  you do not want to miss traditionally  fruitcakes are made with booze but i  decided to substitute it with orange  juice to make it friendly for kids and  everyone else fruitcakes call for moscow  butter sugar which is a more of a  molassy brown sugar but you do not have  that you could substitute it with a  combination of dark brown sugar and  light brown sugar for that flavor  oh yes  [Music]  you